Hello and welcome back.
Now, in our previous lesson,
we unlocked two achievements
that are fairly easy to get.
The first timer
achievement you get
for playing the game and
the Ot-nay Oo-tay Ight-bray
achievement that you get for
making a not particularly
good guess.
And while it's easy to
earn these achievements,
if you actually want to test
earning these achievements
multiple times, it's
kind of difficult to do,
because you can't
earn them again.
You already have them.
And that brings us to the topic
of the game's management APIs.
Now, as you recall, we provide
a lot of rest end points
for you to unlock achievements,
or anchor in achievements,
or submit score to leaderboards,
and so on and so forth.
We also provide a set
of restricted end points
that allow you to, for instance,
remove a player's scores
from the scoreboard.
Or hide a particular
player who is potentially
cheater from appearing in
the public leaderboard.
Or in this particular
case, we give you
the ability to
reset an achievement
to its original state.
Now, these management
APIs are very powerful,
and you don't want them
falling into the wrong hands.
And so the one
restriction around them
is that they can only be called
in your application by people
you have listed as testers.
So remember, if we go back
here to the developer console,
and we click on
little testing link,
only the people
who are added here
will be able to
make these calls.
Which, if you think about
it, kind of makes sense.
You don't want
your average player
to be able to reset
their achievements.
They would probably be
very mad if somehow they
accidentally did that.
And so in my case, because I
am testing with my development
account, I will be able to
make these calls pretty easily.
Now, how do we make these calls?
If you've been investigating
at the library at all,
or viewing the documentation,
or playing around
with the auto
complete, you might
notice that we have a couple
of pretty nifty functions.
Let me go into my
achievement manager here.
For instance, once you
have a GPG achievement,
you can actually call--
we'll call unlock me,
reset achievement with
completion handler.
And and this would make a
call to our management APIs,
and say, hi, please reset
this particular achievement
for this player.
And the results
will be passed back
in this completion handler.
Similarly, we also have a
class method GPG achievement
reset all achievements
with completion handler.
And this does the same thing,
except that it basically
resets all achievements
for the player.
And this seems like this
is pretty useful, right?
You can kind of-- I could
hook up a button within my app
maybe, called QA debugging,
that brings up another view
controller that has a few
buttons that would link
to a reset all achievements
method, and reset my scores,
leaderboards method,
and so on and so forth.
There's just one
tiny little problem,
which is that these calls
don't work right now.
The team knows about it,
they have promised me
that there will be
a fix in an upcoming
version of the library, however,
that's not available here
for my screencast,
and that makes me sad.
But only a little sad,
because you know what?
We can still make these
calls the old fashioned way,
by directly accessing
the rest end points.
So let's do that.
This will be kind of
a fun little refresher
course on how to make
these REST calls.
So, first thing,
let's delete this.
Keep our code nice and tidy.
Now, the first thing
we're going to need to do
is get our access token
to make this call.
And so I can go back into
my game view controller,
sorry my intro view
controller here.
And you'll notice this
is where I commented up
this section, where I blog,
hey, here's our auth object.
But let's go ahead and
get our access token back,
so we can make some-- authorize
some calls outside of our game.
So first thing, I'm going to
scroll up to the top here,
and I'm going to import
GoogleOpenSource/GoogleOpenSource.h.
And now, I'm going
to go down in here,
and if there's no error
NSLog, our access token
is this string.
And we'll call auth.accessToken.
Let's run this, and you can
see right here in our console,
I now have an access
token that I can use.
So I'm going to copy this and
the next thing I'm going to do
is bring up my
terminal, or iTerm,
and I'm going to
make a curl call.
So if you're on an OSX
device, it's Linux-based,
and so you have this
nifty little utility
called curl that
allows you to basically
access pages or other
resources over HTTP directly.
So I'm going to do this.
Go to curl https,
googleapis.com/games/v1/players/me/achievements.
And our access token
equals this thing.
And here we have a list
of our achievements
and their current status.
We've got a couple
that are unlocked,
one that's revealed
but not earned
and another that's
revealed but not earned,
but we've made some steps
towards completing it.
This one is very clearly our
Centiguesser achievement.
By the way, in case
you're wondering,
how did I know what
this giant URL is,
it's in our documentation.
So if you were to go to
developers.google.com/games/services,
You can go to the web here,
look at rest API reference,
and here's a bunch
of calls you can get.
So under achievements,
achievement list
was actually the
call that I made.
And you can see, here's the URL,
games/v1/players, the player
ID, in this case
entering me just
means the player who is
making this call as identified
by the access token.
And this will list
the achievements.
Now this is good,
but this lesson
is really about the
management APIs.
So we're going to look at
this management API reference,
and under here
under achievements,
we have a couple of methods,
reset and reset all.
So let's look at this.
So if we want to reset
a specific achievement,
looks like we can do that
by making a post call here,
and passing in some data where
our achievement ID equals
the achievement ID.
It's a string.
So now let's pick one that
we actually want to reset,
according to-- so
this one ending in AE
is our Ot-nay Oo-tay
Ight-bray achievement.
Yours is probably different,
but, we can look at this
and figure out the call to make.
So I'm going to
make a curl call to
https://www.googleapis.com/games/v1management--
again, that's V1 management,
not v1, /achievements/-- and
it's this thing ending in AE
/reset.
And our access token
equals this thing
we had copied and
pasted earlier.
And then we also need to
pass in the same achievement
ID you can see here as
data in our post call.
And we can do that
just by adding dash
d, achievement, ID equals.
And then we paste
back in this thing.
We enter that, and it
tells us, oh OK, it
looks like that
achievement is now hidden.
And again, if we were to list
our achievements directly,
we could see that we now we
have our revealed, not earned,
revealed incremental,
unlocked and hidden.
And let's look at our reset all.
And this one looks
even easier, we're
just doing a call to
achievement/reset.
So I'm going to-- you know what?
We can just copy and paste this.
Oops, it's giving me
a not found error,
probably because I did not
put in pass in my access
token equals, and again we
can paste in this access token
that we got for our console.
Oh, I guess we're
still getting an error,
and OK, this is because
curl is by default sending
this is as a get,
and if you'll notice,
this call is actually
a post request.
So I think I can force
this to be a post just
by adding some data here.
Yeah, there we go It sends back,
by the way, which achievements
have now been reset.
So it looks like we had
two other achievements,
our incremental achievement,
and our first timer
achievement, that
have been reset now.
And again, if I were to do a
quick look at our achievements,
we can see they're all now
back in their initial state.
So let's go back to our app.
By the way if I were to
click achievements right now,
my guess is-- yeah,
it's cached this data,
it doesn't know that
anything's changed yet.
So it'll still give us this.
Not unexpected, so
the best thing to do
is just-- we'll quit
this, run it again,
get the-- we'll force the
library to fetch new data.
And now we can look
at our achievements,
and i can once again
see that they're empty.
And hooray, now we can
go about making sure
that we've earned
them correctly.
So we can now go ahead and--
I'm going to guess 50 again,
and-- we still got the Ot-nay
Oo-tay Ight-bray achievement,
that is now freshly unlocked.
And we could do this
again any time our tester
needs to go through
the QA plant.
And so, digging up
your access token,
making this curl call, not
hugely convenient, but still
pretty easy to do.
Particularly if
you're developer,
and I'm guessing
most of you are.
There are a few other
ways we could do this.
The other will be to wait
for this library to be fixed.
And build your own
end game interface.
Again, once there's an
update to the library,
I will post a screencast
that shows you
exactly how to do that.
It should also be
noted that if you
were to look at
our downloads page,
there's a link to a utility
called Management Tools.
And this is an
application that can
make all of these management
API calls for you.
This is something that you
would set up and run, say,
on Localhost, or on
your own web server.
And basically, it just automates
grabbing your access token,
and making these REST
calls on your behalf,
without your having
to enter them
in manually as a curl call.
So I encourage you
to check this out,
this would be particularly
useful for development.
It also contains
some tools you might
want to use post launch,
for some community support.
And maybe if there's
enough interest,
I'll create a series of
screencasts on this as well.
But, hey, let's not
get too distracted.
We have other iOS
stuff to finish first.
We've gotten our achievements,
and we've gotten them working,
and we've shown you how to earn
them, how to increment them,
how to reset them so
you can test them again.
But we haven't done anything
with our leaderboards.
Now luckily, most of the
process for leaderboards
is fairly similar to what
we did with achievements.
So this next section
should be pretty easy.
So stay tuned, and I'll
see you in the next lesson.
Bye.